[Music]
real explorers in boulder city has
rolled out its summer program and it's
taking our hot desert weather into
account
we're going to do a 6 30 a.m sunrise
with mimosas
we're going to do this is one of my
favorites we're gonna do a super soaker
ride
at 8 30 in the morning so it's basically
a water gun fight between
our staff and um uh the riders
so that that's gonna be fun and then
we're gonna close down for the day and
then we're gonna open back up again
at 8pm and do a twilight ride and
then of course it's not vegas without
our neon so we have
uh we've got our bikes all lit up and
we've got a neon ride going out uh twice
a night
i love it of course since the activity
is outdoors it's been running throughout
the pandemic providing outdoor fun and
exercise for locals and tourists to
ride the rails on the pedal-powered rail
bikes now they'll have the black lights
neon lights and tons of fun for the
evening rides that she mentioned
they do offer 10 discount for nevada
residents oh
look at the fur baby and new for the
summer as well they're launching a
promotion in coordination with fox's
barbecue in boulder city so
you get a buy 150 off for a particular
pork sandwich
yummy